[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy the Islamic state Isis recently
released a poster depicting Pope Francis
beheaded following quickly after its
threat to attack the Vatican and draw
Christmas blood if the Pope has been a
Christ of this he must feel a little bit
annoyed at their ingratitude after all
he has done for Islam this is the thanks
he gets
after all last September Pope Francis
met in the Vatican with dr. Mohammed bin
abdul kareem elisa
the secretary-general of the muslim
world league a group that has been
linked to the financing of jihad terror
during the meeting elisa thanked the
pope for his fair positions on what he
called the false claims that linked
extremism and violence to his long nor
was that the first time that a Muslim
leader has thanked the Pope for being so
very useful Ahmed el-tayeb the grand
Imam of Cairo's al-azhar thanked him for
his defense of Islam against the
accusation of violence and terrorism ap
reported that the Pope embraced the
grand Imam of al-azhar the prestigious
Sunni Muslim center of learning
reopening an important channel for
Catholic Muslim dialogue after a
five-year law and at a time of increased
Islamic extremist attacks on Christians
now why had there been that five year
low because the Cairo based al-azhar
says the AP report froze talks with the
Vatican to protest comments by then pope
benedict xvi what did benedict say
andrea Godley our duty of the catholic
news agency explains that after a jihad
terrorists murdered 23 christians in a
church in alexandria egypt in 2011
benedict decried terrorism and the
strategy of violence against Christians
and called for the Christians of the
Middle East to be protected Ahmed
el-tayeb was furious he railed at
Benedict for his interference in Egypt's
affairs
and warned of a negative political
reaction to the Pope's remarks in a
statement al-azhar denounced the Pope's
repeated negative references to Islam
and his claims that Muslims persecute
those living among them in the Middle
East
Benedict stood his ground and that was
that but in September 2013 al-azhar
announced that Pope Francis had sent a
personal message to Altai yet in it
according to al-azhar Francis declared
his respect for Islam and his desire to
achieve mutual understanding between the
world's Christians and Muslims in order
to build peace and justice at the same
time Altai yet met with the Apostolic
Nuncio to Egypt Monsignor jean-paul go
bail and told him in no uncertain terms
that speaking about Islam in a negative
manner was a red line that must not be
crossed so to recap
Pope Benedict condemned a jihad attack
one that al-azhar had also condemned and
yet alas are suspended dialogue because
of the Pope's condemnation then Pope
Francis wrote to the grand Sheikh of
al-azhar affirming his respect for Islam
and the grand Sheikh warned him that
criticizing Islam was a red line that he
must not cross this makes it clear that
the dialogue that Pope Francis has now
reestablished will not be allowed to
discuss the Muslim persecution of
Christians that it continues to escalate
worldwide especially since an incidents
of that persecution led to the
suspension of dialogue in the first
place what's more his dialogue partner
al tyub has shown himself over the years
to be anything but a preacher of peace
cooperation and mercy he is justified
anti-semitism on Quranic grounds and
called for the Islamic state murderers
of the Jordanian pilot to be crucified
and have their hands and feet amputated
on opposite sides as per the penalty in
chapter 5 verse 33 of the Quran for
those who make war against Allah and His
Messenger or spread mischief in the land
al-azhar was also revealed to be
offering free copies of a book that
called for the slaughter of Christians
and other infidels
Frances for his part proclaimed that
authentic Islam and the proper
understanding of the Quran reject every
form of violence doing his bit to ensure
that as many Christians as possible
would remain ignorant and complacent
about the jihad threat that his precious
dialog does nothing whatsoever to
mitigate and now Isis has called for his
head
if this Pope does lose his head would
anyone notice he is a disgrace to the
church to judeo-christian civilization
and to the free world
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]